se necesitaron meses de negociaciones
secretas previas y la aceleración de los
atentados en argel y parís a principios
de 1962 para que finalmente después de
ocho años de guerra cruenta las
conversaciones de piano se inaugurarán
oficialmente el 7 de marzo de 1962 entre
el gobierno francés y el ala política
del frente de liberación nacional la
conferencia duró 11 días tras las
conversaciones se estancaron
notablemente en dos temas el futuro de
la comunidad francesa residente en
argelia que finalmente no fue resuelto
por el acuerdo y la cuestión de la
soberanía del sahara
parís exigió y consiguió mantener
durante varios años el control de la
región donde los intereses petroleros y
nucleares franceses eran importantes
[Música]
el 18 de marzo de 1962 se firmaron los
acuerdos de bien con un alto el fuego
que entró en vigor al mediodía del día
siguiente esa misma noche el general de
gaulle se dirigió a los franceses lo es
las disposiciones se adoptan para que
las poblaciones puedan disponer de su
destino y perspectiva del procedimiento
de un ángel independiente cooperando
estrechamente con nosotros satisface la
razón de formular eso pedazos
en realidad la violencia continuarían
largos meses
lado a ese organización armada
clandestina formada por los partidos de
argelia francesa multiplicó los ataques
el fmln tomó represalias con asesinatos
y secuestros de europeos sospechosos de
estar cerca de la organización pero el
proceso de independencia previsto en los
acuerdos debía era inevitable en medio
de la atención el primero de julio de
1962 la población votó masivamente por
el sí a la independencia de argelia el
mismo día de una jornada sangrienta la
masacre de orán la inseguridad y la
violencia provocaron el éxodo hacia la
metrópoli de casi un millón de pies no a
pies negros personas de origen francés
que vivían en argelia en los barcos
había también unos 10.000 harkis
argelinos que hicieron parte del
ejército francés que permanecieron en
argelia y fueron a menudo víctimas de
represalias una dolorosa repatriación
cuyas heridas aún se sienten hoy en día